[Musique]
mais l'ua sans filtre le podcast où on
parle de ce qu'on veut que nos invités
dati seach ph quand tu es avec moi de me
plante c'est semaine au podcast
l'humoriste est rosalie côté d'année par
mois
c'est bon là c'est que je suis quelqu'un
on est trop craqué par l'accord rose
hill vaillancourt humoriste et son choix
faroy en rodage à l'éthique est ce un
podcast roman humoristique le pot grandi
petit grand chose de très sérieux ça a
été pas mal le déconnage pendant 1h15
fait que koul déconnage enjoy puis
entendu vraiment fun j'espère que vous
êtes aussi venus nous encourager sur pet
rien nous risquons à du contenu exclusif
on n'allait pas de casse en avance je
pouvais avoir nom générique toute
l'équipe
allez voir sur la description et dans la
vie des orphelins le lien est dans la
description de la vidéo ici
sinon abonnez vous sur notre chaîne
youtube commenter ce que vous pensez
l'addition avec rosalie parler nous on
vous aime pied bon podcast bonne écoute
[Musique]
salut les gars derrière un court ça va
bien pas très bien toi c'est quoi ton
dominique dame nec ph et du faux bien
hélène entendu plein d'affaires mais
pierre héland c'est la première fois
mais c'est pour pascal go asca légaux et
je le rappelle aux primaires les
masseurs avait dit à tout le monde que
c'est pour pierre henry le pourquoi et
dans les chais je suis seul à faire
parce qu'après ça moi je était au début
j'ai remarqué qu'elle publiait plein nez
moi j'ai décidé comme que la leblat la
blague était terminé il fait léger à
tout moment c'est parce que le groupe le
masseur la crise alors pas arrêter la
blague
pierre envies d'ailleurs de chiens mais
les gens tapent les pierre-henri où les
gens tapaient ph
les gens humbles et ph change rien
vraiment au d'étudier mais je n'ai
présumé ressort à rouler comme je peux
me faire chier on de thc drôle si ça
fait maintenant penser à de la science
les berges de l'aude
les pirogues coupet erding qui connaît
des pierres je connais des pierrugues
combien et pour des auteurs comme victor
hugo puis sûrement un pascal comme des
grands auteurs ton nom en hommage de la
perse pascal non ça sera bon quand même
ça serait pas peur mais c'est vraiment
pas pour se c'était supposé dimitri mes
parents turcs adam erne coca
pourquoi on touche au québec avant quand
un kiné htc magic un navire était
différente même si taper dimitri d'un
bout à l'autre serait probablement
inconnu
est ce que tu dis mais c'est vrai je
réussis parrish a été comme choisi avec
passé en deux ans
tant mieux de famille pourquoi parce que
moi je n'écoute pas non plus les
coûteuses pour cette année j'écoutais ça
n'est pas ce qui m'arrive t ha à la fin
des kippas son double et il est dimanche
ouais ouais comme invité pas que j'avais
dû écouter une émission choc était bien
monté ce test est comique mais c'est que
des fois plus qu'un mec est 7e ces lots
si j'ai un bac à 100% j'ai donné un ton
et un style ouais j'avoue loire si tout
le monde peut alors être leur ami
c'était quoi la les stocker sur lesquels
fallait face des gags et je pense à
l'épisode ce qu'ils mangeaient une
boulette il mange prie aime bien que si
j'en ai la fgtb juste fait notre boulot
lors des troubles
ouais centre un trou de balle mais
promet d'être un nom n'était pas le
financer et puis c'est sandrine on se
presse andré que ces langues
non rennes on peut trouver ça drôle et
201 k 5 / 100 g avec les hommes parce
que je trouve tout à rebours semble dans
ma tête oui les cheveux les yeux est
sorti un peu plus groupe la barbe
je pense que c'est grâce à sa hausse
existence sape et sexy c'est pas dans la
personnalité une fois vous parlez je
vais encore vous parlez pas pareil team
c'est plaisant le physique encore tout
les goûts sur sa voix de robot
commencerait tout pas beau
porter des pantalons un peu c'est
vraiment mais l'engin s'est déjà vu le
temps qui a passé ans qu'il fait où il
sort du lot ouais je connais pas leur
cas n'est pas le poids des jeux plus si
par les exploitants à -38 voir au québec
basescu mais c'est vrai que nous autres
on reconnaît les filles par axa c'est la
fille au jeu
la fille aux claude courte c'est
vraiment parlé moi je t'ai gt gt
découvert mais je découvre la première
fois je t'ai entendu j'avais vraiment
tendre sur les tournois je t'ai entendu
que je t'ai vu c'était en même temps que
la culture du viol ah oui ouais ouais je
faisais un numéro le numéro c'était
drôle en cristaux de glace et j'en
parlais avec ma blonde en maths on est
allé les deux ensembles pièce très bon
puis à partir de là c'est tout ce que
j'avais fait
tu faisais une espèce de numéros sur ton
constat que la femme en tabarnak parce
que ton stock avait arrêté de tous temps
qu'il oui a commencé à 100 kg de maïs
j'écris ce thème en un seul mot c'est
comme si déjà tu me fait sentir nous le
pico ne fait moins sentir spéciale
[Rires]
numérotée effet droite chaudes c'était
trop rock je pense pour les gens qui
fait quand même intense ouais c'est très
bref comme numéro c'est assez cru paquet
je mettais tout mes numéros sont assez
mélangé j'ai peaufiné ses appuis j'ai
juste gardé maintenant je m'en des
images et des choses que je reçois et
parce que même les centres anti les
flics monclar d'une [ __ ] qui reçoivent
trouve ça correct c'est une façon d
comme des phares comme un genre j'en
reçois puceau mais moi c'est juste que
je sais que les filles de 13 ans qui me
suis dit comme je peux qu'un premier
pénis à soissons
ce qui est il un pénis c'est spécial que
mon premier pc jean paul monchau mais
c'est mon ami trizay maigre un kéké
d'acier avec huawei
c'est devenu mon ami a presque mais
c'est juste qu'il faut contacter mais
non ça reste pour toute ta vie
puis il avait il ya justice et short et
parce qu'il y avait du fun j'avais très
envie blablabla puis j'avais sept comme
au magot son premier sa réaction
initiale si je vais y penser pendant des
semaines puis ça s'est fini par estampes
et maintenant je m'en souviens plus des
messages de plus lâche bac mais
j'imagine que effectivement toutes les
jeunes filles de 13 ans qui suivait
marina mazza qui ont vu les gros pénis
en érection qu'elle a partagées sur
instagram c'est cela leur première
création
j'ai une responsabilité c'est dommage
oui je le suis à ce poste là directement
choisi la page pour eux pas de casser
commencé quand on a parlé de ton premier
pénis c'est que c'est plate pour eux ça
va mais dans ce cas c'est dessus avant
ou après mouvement mythomane ou pas mais
je l'avais qui en fait est avant est mis
tous ses animaux je faisais pour le gard
le comédia de 2017 2007 j'avais fait un
an avant en fait si tu apprécies tu te
dis ouais c'est dodo clou de la tête que
je la gîte non parce que choqué ça monte
exactement ce qu'il faut montrer ses
fesses et et lads jockeys
finalement ces chiens cruz est mon ami
c'est juste drôle
enfin ça fait genre un revirement
comique mais ça ce que je montrais en
fait j'ai passé ce délai les choses qui
m'envoyait pour les gens étaient connues
et elles aiment violi factice t'es sûr
que les gens étaient genre ça faisait un
petit marais sur le gala matin sa ligne
du fret
seppi moi ça me battrai jusqu au mans il
ya des choses qu'on a besoin de parler
j'ai des textes fixant comme sur mon
chien
on était juste à manger à aligner les
chansons comme à votre sourire la
trisomie mais non les sécheresses
n'agirait pas sur ta couche à la phase 5
est un contexte d'un gala qui s'appelait
phoque la culture du viol de ses échecs
de toute évidence tout d'abord le numéro
de jeu avec un espèce de préavis de 6 à
ce repas dansant ce ne soit pas un sens
que tu penses avoir été assez claire
mais j'avoue que dans un cadeau est ce
que tu t'attends pas les gens certains
disent amant pas utiliser le nom sonne t
fond jugeant ait eu effrayante
on voulait quelque chose encore
sceptiques madame say you pote deuxième
niveau est sa deuxième du bon j'essaie
je sais c'est atroce et j'en parle mais
fois ci à des jo qui pensent que le
chairman années dans mon choix qui j'ai
une urne
ça c'est le choc mon ex la prochaine
fois je ferai appel à un professionnel
pas sa toute prochaine il faut piler
gens iront aux petits corps c'est vrai
quand ils sont tous tombés comme un
socle et la même rue qui faisait quand
exactement mais passés ge com mais il
faut apprendre il faut avoir
l'intelligence des textes la mode
inséré dans un show d'humour mauvais
mais sans les jantes et je pense qu'il
faut les tenir par la main des fois
c'est une fois que son temps marqué ça
veut mais c'est un humour qui est un peu
plus
je pense qu'il est plus jeune l'humour
absurde
ouais c'est deuxième niveau qui est des
fois les gens en l'amusant puis on a
beaucoup entendu parler du deuxième
niveau
selon guy nantel m'attend mais ces
pannes et sa malle deuxième un peu c'est
un peu dans le succès de mike ward le au
fil de ces au fil des années en fait le
qui était basé un peu sur ce plan je
pense que le public de mcqueen c'est
vraiment eu
de renouveler puis préciser c'est que
ces gens là avec son plus jeune qui ont
une crainte qui accepte ce genre
d'humour l'heure c'est dû suivre un peu
tout six humoristes l'ofppt et avec le
même la même vision du deuxième niveau 6
tu vas voir un show de mike ward depuis
que tu es facilement opus câble n'est
pas bonne place mais voici voilà je me
suis quand même un peu
ouais y'a des fois jusqu'à sarine pour
mac la jaa vrais mobiles type ok ça chie
dessus jusqu'à pas seulement pour les
choses un peu méchante série m'attend
c'est maintenant le ghana avec ouais
mais ça fait longtemps fait une grosse
un franc succès le premier podcast
ils sont comme reparler après plus de
gens m'ont montré que c'était de l'eau
avait coulé sous les ponts musique et à
l'aide
mais si je me souviens ce qu'avait dit
non il ya de l'eau suspens clémence
catherin de mort dipc
ouais bah si c'est la magie comme plus
amusant avec ce lot est comme ça va plus
je suis quand même cru sectionnement
petit mais des fois je fais monter ma
mère à l'issue du stage jamais été
c'est le batteur salavat je ne suis
jamais content in 2,6 avant que je pense
que c'était genre à like you tube joe
cole même changé mais je veux pour
niaiser ou bêtes étaient au jeu saute n
2 comme une personne normale
non je faisais pour nous j'avais ma
collègue
non non
jamais mais une fois quand j'étais en
thaïlande mais c'était pas une dead line
2 parce que j'ai marqué le king for
friends en majuscules et en thaïlande
pendant toute ma soeur qui le fasse en
était comme j'ai pu de conversation à
voir avec toi j'ai tout parler mes
conversations je tournais toi raconte à
léon dette avec genre 12 australiens
asiatique s'est pas fait puis on est
prêt à tourner pour s'approcher jusqu'à
prévu les contrats juteux sur facebook
il ya des dates et 11,3 au serait pas
seul ban avait inquiet je pense que
c'est pour looking for fun
madame madame looking for la dame si
j'avais apporté je maîtrise
je pense quand même à temps des gens
connus qui sont certes n 2 bat 6,6
pourquoi pas et moi je serai jamais le
bâtiment commente jérôme c'est après que
déjà please please
j'ai besoin de six benjamins
c'est la raison que dé sur tender's
parce que tu as besoin de sexe je
pourrais sûrement n'avoir pas su retenir
facilement mais c'est seulement parce
qu'ils
j'essaie pas fous rires mais je sais pas
parce que j'ai pas la mx 1 7 tonne de
harwich jarny cour a déjà connu que je
ne vois pas ces clips au poignet à la
réputation des loups josé socrates s'il
a su trouver des fonds on faisait le fun
comme sur chatroulette la tradition
perdure on a surtout hâte rôle et on
essaie de se trouver m chatroulette faut
que c'est la cinquième grève et la
trousse est un phénomène
ok j'en aie c'est la meilleure genre le
summum de l'humanité ce conte pour en
ligne rencontrer des gens nous mêmes
systèmes quantiques en première chose
que les gens font sur chatroulette mais
attends mais satie moi si ça m'arrive
c'est une ou deux fois quand je vais
mais moi ce que je préfère c'est jean
rigaud timide je faisais on entend des
claviers mis par l'épaule avec luc maton
en partie de france ont le toupet de
ziralo salut saveur mais sans oublier
fermer son 6ème et sa façade arrière
démange ou les sorties athlètes
je pensais que c'était internationales
comme les gens qui sont dans ta vie tu
pas que des gens qui sont pas si
lointain fait sais pas où leur droit et
de hockey en prêt à aller en autant
d'années règne dans mon rayon personnes
viennent québec fasquel le tender rien
n'est fixé maintenant
ouais et si vous ennuyer de québec c'est
le fun oui c'est enfin massive était
souvent pour la tournée que j'aime
tellement ce la seule chose que j'aime
pas de québec sur les radios mais à quel
prix
fermez changer de poste ce message fait
sans dégâts
moi j'écoute juste 106.3 tout cas de
radio de québec
bah oui du canada québec mais non pas
des choses qui viennent oui mais radio
de l'option félix il y avait coûté 10
mais non québécois moi je m'ennuie
québec est passé les gens de québec qui
s'ennuient tellement de cette fois ça
fait j'attends pas ok ok avec un bas
depuis octobre
mais non mais le double but ben ali
c'est à cause de balises enfants qui
n'ont fait aucune ag tout de suite
ensemble d'api et jesse way the game
ouais c'était facile adaptation
visiteurs venus ensemble des postes off
mais est-ce que vous avez des ménages
ensemble ouais mais non c'est moi parce
que vous avez peur au téléphone ouais
c'est ça vous avez tout loisir mais
j'arrive les talibans après 3,7 à
d'accepter les cartes vous voulez où tu
peux rien [ __ ] rien pantoute
mais c'est moi j'ai pas facile à vivre
avec
pourquoi j'ai quand même de faire comme
quoi le ménage entre espace propre
cuisine rien mais cela les cartables
progresser ça si on est pour ça que le
géant goise parce que parce qu'on en un
studio où est ce qu'on va déménager pour
faire les podcasts
puis tout ça c'est le stock de studio
mais là c'est comme l'attendait mais
c'est comme l'assiette
maintenant il faut qu'ils me prouvent
que red bull partie du prince est soit
jamais se redresser lentement elle est
sage a mieux c'est parce que j'aime de
laquelle une petite fille que tu veux tu
t'étais dessus de briser ce que les gens
y y et mme bois puis il se fond dans
l'opinion puisse cette opinion le cas ce
possible négative où qu'ils soient sur
scène ce processus est une grosse salle
j'aime les deux si je commence à payer
je pense que c'est une présence après
récurrence question de procès ce qui
rend sa drôle c'est que quand punch avec
un dock trash c'est comme deux fois plus
surprenant pas ça sort de la bouche
parce que c'est
moi je pense qu'il peut y avoir 60 ans
ça va être plus drôle encore si je vais
vraiment ma grand-mère avec des petits
papillons sexuelle c'est bon c'est bon
attendez veiller personnellement à
parler de bleu nuit lundi je tombais sur
100 mais je l'écoutais peau j'ai quand
même essayé y aller chez les pontons
cadence epsilon j'ai commencé ma mise
assez simple dames en 2019
quelque chose s'appelle l'internet
quelqu'un qui calait je vais pas nommer
ici pour pour par respect raconter
l'histoire dans sa famille où est-ce que
amener ses partenaires tout le monde mon
père a parlé de sexe dans ma famille
plats gras marque hitachi qui dit pas un
mot tous les bus en fait juste drop est
en tout cas moi je n'ai jamais manger la
banane le tout le monde fait comme les
grandes grappes et genre mamie gros
froids qu'est ce qu'elle voulait dire
par jamais à jamais son format il pilote
le monde fait comme tout site sur la
plogue sur un parti qui comme tout le
monde commence à être un peu chaud plat
moi j'arrête est fixé à poser des
questions on ne sait jamais où je pense
que c'est parce qu'il était déçu je sais
pas mais sûrement le montant que c'est
normal
le grand paris se rend compte que
finalement lui ce que lui son expérience
à lui renvoie la balle à ce moment là
britannique fasse le point sur sa
calculé qu'elles étaient fausses mais là
on conviendra enfin cette femme je sais
pas
social angel jamais la banane qui y
avait une façon de plonger le québec
[Rires]
excusez moi mais c'est drôle en personne
parce que on va dire oui c'est comme pas
être gênés où j'ai cette absurde un peu
le mot des vielles personnes membres en
parler tellement drôle
comme il fait tout temps des blagues
puis maghrébins comme le guil on arrête
là ils vont penser que tu es fou bien
comme moi je peu fou je peux vous bim
hisser vers le bas sa taille claude jeu
pour me monter des peuples mais j'ai
tellement trouvé ça drôle
c'est comme ces joueurs du monde mais
moi j'ai un davantage et tout le confort
de tous deux ouais mais les vieilles
personnes extrait le pitch on le sait
c'est ce que je préfère c'est tout cas
pas tous les enfants sont déviés
personnes passaient cmc mes deux
passions au t2 mais vraiment mais en
même temps c'est que j'ai encore j'ai
encore un support gêne pas que je peux
je peux jarnisy comme un bébé
mais si clairement donné quand j'avais
des enfants mais ça va être ce qu'ils
vont être horribles
j'étais très concentré sur sa carrière
devenir vieille j'adore venir
madame parce qu'en fait le plein ouais
il à thème bon ya pas de fait le plein
gala sort d'être devenu sénile mais
tellement drôle
cette infirmière puis allez dans soins
palliatifs longtemps fait que des gens
c'est dylan i'm a vu le cool
il ya comme lui était médecin fait que
sa veste et quoi attirer les cinq gars
de d'avant-garde les secours est en
cours on nous accuse pas d'engagement
coureurs le chili a fait il fait ça
marche fort puis il le vrai caractère
quel genre si tu arrivais plus il y
avait comme oubliée son ampli faisait
comme s'ils avaient oublié son nom
mais genre comme comme quelqu'un qui
veut essayer de cacher le fait qu'ils
ont bien son nom le fait comme s'ils
avaient oublié cette équipe là ouais ok
tu qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que tu viens
chercher ici comme essayer de jouer ce
mec est tellement bon animations et
sorties de chez mon copain à les appeler
ma mère l'a dit maman papy sénile que le
nom leur appareil sorti plus qu'en
fauteuil
paniquée la gorge pour ça ouais je vais
être dit gallas est vraiment et j'ai
déjà pensé de ce genre les petites
habile été transparent avec des plumes
au bout ici des gens vous savez c'est
quoi je parle moi je ne me bats pas
attachés de même j'ai fait revenir des
goûts pour nettoyer genre mon autre
qu'allah vous faire l'objet être comme
un way s'est enfui par des flamands même
tellement avant de t'endormir le sort
peut imaginer ce que d'avoir à tous les
jours par exemple jamais la prochaine c1
c'est vraiment un domaine où est ce que
la retraite est pas quelque chose de
réellement discuté mayer déjà que la
retraite mais dans les marais c'est
qu'on a on ne peut du maurice et ça fait
pas entendre un cri morizet ce qui n
était
mais envoie moi j'avais vu comme quatre
fois cette année encore le dcc dans ma
tête retraite c'était en italie où tu es
en train de faire des voyages exactement
moi c'est comme ça que c'est un genre
comme si tu veux être sûre de moi je
pense qu'on est en train de devenir des
surhumains j'arrête pas de penser à ce
qui m'attend mais à midi c'était vrai
test ici parce que des fois je parle ils
disent que je parle comme si j'étais un
gosse pilotes en devenir des super
humain n'était qu'un petit prince du
meilleur du but pour le maire de la
fille tu fais des humains ces trois
matches exactement c'est exactement
comme si je voulais dire
michi mais un genre où je ne sais pas
mais pas nécessairement c'est juste
qu'on va dernière les qualités de
battant et les affaires qui est comme
lego font plus où les filles font plus
tout ça ça va se mélanger puis aura plus
de ce que puis-je à une physique même
baissé de même ça va juste des êtres
humains peuvent pas quand même 4 enlève
tout le l'influenza société puis des
normes qui décode il reste pas quelque
chose de belgique qui fait que kamini
différence à tango puis je me suis pas
assez posé la question à exceller et je
pense que non je pense que c'est comme
simone de beauvoir a dit on n'est pas
femme on le devient
c'est comme quand tu mets deux enfants
de benfica côté le camp son bébé il n'y
a pas de différence est en béton à
puberté la puberté c'est ça qui comme
toi tu être plus de poils en face ça
n'est pas l'écrit encore une fois mais
je ne sais pas je pense qu'il est facile
et des normes la société encore une fois
le facteur c'est peu tec est sale et
très sûrement lève tout sourit celle de
sabots oui parce que c'est comme qu'est
ce qui te dis pas que si il ya 400 ans m
il ya mille ans les femmes ont commencé
à ses plis c'est peut-être la raison
pourquoi on a moins de poils que voulons
c'est paul celle
est aéré de l'évolution peut-être
certaines personnes ne saurait peut-être
pas nous le même temps quelqu'un est
biologiste et d'électro démerde ce
moment on parle de quelque chose qu'on
connaît j'avais la javel à la discussion
ce que ma blonde questionne beaucoup
parce que j'avais la diction chinois
après avoir vu son numéro avec martin
matte
sur le gala de l'école de 50 années
congo les 30 au lit 30 ans et luis pépé
souvient aujourd'hui c'est parce que là
c'était le c'était la parité pour avoir
le numéro 10 est citée comme une façon
vous le faisiez comme si c'était toi
qu'avec son texte à lui qui disait que
ça le vrai elle apparaît tpiy lui
m'avait on n'était pas d'accord qu'on
est amis on était vraiment un conclure
cliquer ils croyaient pas cela pas été
pour moi j'ai dit que je serai à ses
côtés comme le fou écrans numériques on
est d'accord toutes les deux de dire ce
qu'on va dire
puis on a réussi à se mettre d'accord si
un homme jeune comme sur l homme blanc
de 50 ans qui est un peu plus de doigts
depuis une fille hyper de gauche de 25
ans on a un terme à quelque chose
ensemble
saks et sa main et et c'est ma plus
grande fierté c'est bon c'est ça ça veut
dire qu'on est capable dans ces cités de
56 à faire ouais moi j'avais justement
les j'avais la diction hikma blanc parce
que je me disais témoins y avait la
sphère de louge encore bien aussi avec
sa part au festival d'été oui mais il
s'en est mordu les doigts si c'est comme
s'il n'y avait pas assez réfléchi à la
question avant et puis moi tu vois je
reste
je mettais pas posé la question plus
large à winnipeg ma blonde pis
sont ce que elle maudit kiev qui m'a
fait réaliser que mon opinion et
interpol mais pas biaisé mettait pas
abouti ck maudit oui effectivement tué
en mai en voyant la parité t'empêche des
gens mettons des gars plus talentueux ou
how meilleur que des faits de prendre
cette place le sauf que le point que la
nappe ensuite ses droits mais sitôt la
parité il voir plus de filles qui vont
dire moi c'est ça je vais faire parce
que plus de faits qu'il faut c'est un
ancien c'est comme ça c'est comme ça il
faut que je fasse un plan de 120 ans moi
c'est sûr cc comme l'apa et en ce moment
ça va être chiant pour me temps de voir
des gens 500 mètres et ça il ya des
filles dans cinq six ans ils vont avoir
plus puisque j'en ai plus que le talent
se développe tout sur moi je n'avais pas
mais c'est historiquement hystériquement
ccdh même où siroter les droits de vote
au début les familles à l'épaule il ya
les peaux tendreté c'est après cela que
j'en sais maintenant c'est normal pour
nous c'est sûrement que les femmes
votent autant que les analystes
s'intéressent à positiver sur le puits
par rapport à ensuite à la question de
dire est ce qu'il ya des différences
pour le mental physique clairement y est
physique qui en est mentalement je sais
pas je suis dit je sais pas si vite les
hommes mais ça c'est vraiment la
question est intéressante ils ont été
écoulés glace 3 qui sont utilisées par
des hommes pour dire aux mêlées pour
diminuer la femme c'est pour dire à la
fin peut pas être ici peut pas être
sympa ce qui est biologiquement sont pas
capables seppi le cse en fait je me
demande ce qui est fait ses recherches
le cd 51 californie se souvint s'est
basé sur pas grand chose juste un
argument pour 10 pour discréditer mais
tu es
les animaux comme d'autres quel animal
sur marc des différences de comportement
entre les morts dont la femme était
partie c'est pas fou de penser que
peut-être quelqu'un qui en a qui les
recherchent c'est pas nécessairement des
affaires c'est mou je vois pas ce genre
l'exemple sont meilleurs ou positivement
at-il toutefois que les hommes et on est
plus impulsif sur la science le dit ce
sont des traits comme ceux il ya plus
d'hommes et en syrie via leur téléphone
me disait tu biologique ou c'est la
société thomas c'est en suivant des mâts
contrôle en tout qui ont des problèmes
j'aurais le viol quand un tvt commencer
par le tpiy
ils suivent en psychologie après c'est
juste un petit goût violets ne sera pas
la même chose que tu te fais via les ai
pas même genre d'accompagnement je pense
c'est moche pour ce qui est la question
et plus va plus loin que ça parce qu il
l' influence de la société et partout
dans sa vie des années partout dans tout
ce qu'on vit il était difficile de
réduire ce sais que c'est impossible en
fait de réduire sera simplement la base
deux essais ce commentaire comme on dit
on est peu scientifique faut qu'on
progresse et qu'on le sait pas parler
politique des pistes c'est celle qui à
travers les époques à travers les
sociétés disposent les sociétés trompa
règle un str marre d'être et qu'ils sont
constat mais encore une fois tu essaies
ceci cela était dû patriarcal c'était
les utilités comme les cerveaux humains
témoins développer aussi et j'en sais
que les gars sont versés à la discussion
section un petit veulent comprendre le
ccc genre il ya des fois illégal sur
internet qui disent des choses vraiment
et que tu vois qui ayant peur réfléchi
mais qui pour avoir une discussion avec
eux puis il comprendra un peu plus
moi j'ai dit aux filles a franchi tout
petit déjà je comprends que ses forces
en mettant des masques et moi je me fais
ça me fâche et des folles de recevoir
jean trois fois par jour tes bonnes pour
une fille j'aime pas et film les abysses
et mes collègues c'est mes amis c'est du
moins possible pas quelque chose de
positif pour moi qui étais mme pauly
fille d'habitude sont pas de route et
regardons actifs hors japon tout cet pis
si ge a essayé d'expliquer ou genre
copie colle un message qui était la
pippin colonne c'est comme mais c'est du
sila des fois les com de post marché
je comprends mais oui je sais ça fait
apprécier un dock qui plein de bon
boulot en piqué gentil puisqu'il veut
juste comprendre mais tu veux tout de
suite parce qu'elle est en partie des
gens qui va céder la plupart mais quand
même mais c'est une question qui me
transcende qui transcende l'or qui
transcende le de loin lui mocky qui
juste sociétaires puis c'est hier ya
tout le monde en parle il y avait le
sait quoi son nom le gars qui est qui
qui va avec
ouais c'est ça le faisait ces quais
le mans sont que c'était justement pour
agression agression sexuelle puis
système de dire arrêtons de dire les
femmes agressées dont les victimes parce
que lui chantait biaisé dans ce discours
le cas une fois que tu acceptes que tout
le monde est dans la même situation
c'est plus facile d'ouvrir le jeu peut
penser je peux être place de cette fille
là c'est comme entrer quand on peut se
mettre à la place de l'autre sexe
c'est plus facile et quand même ya
beaucoup de réalisateurs à qui je parle
puisque homme pourquoi ton passage
presspass encore un goût encore une fois
le gars c'est le drôle puis on l'a fait
c'est la belote et jeux comme je
comprends papier comme je peux capa
décret pour les filles si je suis comme
dans toute bonne fille écrit pour un
groupe change les textes après puis mais
elle ça change rien on élit même genre
de personne on a tout vécu maintenant on
est est élevé au québec on a tout le
même genre de background est juste mais
tout est en place puis sont comme les
trois autres m'ont dit ça me change et
puis maintenant en train d'écrire un
rôle de fille pixar pas en train de
penser à un rôle de fille
il pense à un rosé aux personnes dans un
rôle de go je sais avec son vécu qu'ils
changent pour une feuille après c'est
comme c'est pas si différente et je
repense je pense à mes amis que puis je
trouve pas qu'on ne vécut tant de choses
différentes que seul en tant que fait
google à part que nous j'ai dédié des
fois qu'on se fait ramasser maintenant
sur le net où il ya des gars qui
comprennent pas la réalité m'attendais
de toutes qu'est ce qui est plus
féminine
mais les relations amoureuses
admettons mais je me remets au
secondaire le puits ligue 1 les faits
avaient pas du tout le même traitement
par rapport aux sorties
popo sortie de long par rapport au
chemin aux relations pour une relation
sexuelle entre classique j écrivais pour
un golf etc pour une fille parce que
justement apprécié sans sucre à
l'hectare
c'est ce que je pense je pense pas ce
qui était le fameux exemple de
commissions
l'asl hauteville gustin king et même si
je pense que les gars qui couche avec
beaucoup de filles je pense pas que les
gens pensent que justin king souvent et
gens simples et même si ça sera jamais
comme père qu'elle affiche l'ucl et moi
je me souviens la ligue 2 était comme
elle je cours avec elle même si elle
avait des maladies les mais je mettrais
fou le condom l'a jeté comme au monde
ils sont en cours d'économie
[Rires]
c'est là je n'en avais plus et qui
m'avait conduit cette jokela mais
maintenant je réalise ces jo clé c'est
qu'on reste sicav c'était de dire une
clé qui ouvre plein qu'à menace d'un
master qui vint kanaky s'ouvrir par
planck les camardes la philosophie le
parallèle est il faut oublier que c'est
marion n'est pas décapité marche parce
que les analogies boîte mais on s'entend
que jack était acceptée puis que c'était
sa prison ça a pris du temps puis même
de construire six des leurs pour une
faillite immense souvent des fois qu'ils
cherchaient quelqu'un que l'on demande
si je me sens pour l'image mais sans
salle puis comme et a tenté j'ai le
droit
voyons donc je me sens mal nécessaire
mais c'est comme si je pense que pour
une fille comment ça aurait peut-être un
petit peu plus chaud fait que
je sais maintenant l'idée puis
maintenant tgd army ils font ce qu'ils
veulent n'en parle même plus dans nos
prestations de commandes était super
[Musique]
hornet parce que gay s'est levé puis à
la sphère des riffs avait les mains car
passer à la fenêtre mais moi j'étais
toujours dans la vie tu fais ce que tu
veux
c'est ce moment que ça fait de mal à
personne mais évidemment mais
honnêtement il ya beaucoup de fils c'est
vraiment très sorcier vraiment beaucoup
de gaieté que je pensais qu'il est
efféminé sons et des discussions se
féminise on ait des discussions sur la
légalité mais où ce que ça stoppe c'est
la sexualité de la femme est tout le
temps je pays
j'ai mon assiette mamelon dans l'époque
j'avais comme 50go trouve son corps
genre de l'image [ __ ] puisque moi même
si l'image ne peuvent au petit pense
qu'ils sont toutes en même temps et puis
c'est quand même encore une fois ces
genres quand j'ai dit à mes amis que les
portons avec son ex parce qu il savait
qu'elle avait couché avec cinq groupes
en inquiéter mais pourquoi
et comme je laime mais j'ai pas capable
de penser qu'elle est plus on sait pas
sentimental cg ja pour moi une fille ça
doit être demain puis je sais que je
pense que c'est mieux mais il ya des
gars qui genre pauvresse et les gaffes
et mené 7-6 les gars comme on aime tout
le monde les aime
mais sur ce sont tellement arrêté c'est
comme le corps de la femme ça doit être
sacré mais seul c'est plus agricole d'un
peu possessif jaloux la dame et c'est
cet amour parce que souvent les
relations hommes-femmes ces contrôles
n'étaient qui contre le couac entre le
quoi tout le monde veut savoir ce que
c'est qu'il a besoin d'amis mais n'y a
pas de bosse et voyons donc ouais mais
là des relations pareil souvent s'il ya
dynamique s'installe les pistes qui sont
à cannes a un qui a eu un peu plus de
pouvoir ou que c'est y arrivant sur le
corps de l'autre match au centre mais
c'est pas
souvent ces réactions le sont pas son
port réfléchit le tir c'est juste un
recensement de phares au début comme sa
check in that chick peas et c'est que
c'est dépassé même pas si réfléchissez
jusqu'à son hip hop peut s'en empêcher
un sou c'est comme ça ce pour une fille
ça se donnait peur ouais mais j'avoue
que c'est la pensée qu'il faut que ce
comté
pour dessus activement lutte contre ce
réflexe lui c'est quand même un peu le
devoir de la personne là bas si tu peux
faire le chemin inverse et non sa part
rapport c'est ça c'est ça c'est vraiment
cessé lutter contre ses propres pour un
cabas de fois faudra se remettre en
question de lutter contre sa pige et
j'écoutais vous rappelle plus ce n'était
pas le cas ces deux humoristes que
j'écoute puis je m'appuie séculaire
invités qui disait une façon de lutter
contre les jalousies c'est d'y penser
constamment etc lui 10e et on lui avait
eu des problèmes de jalousie lui-même en
mer sa blonde qui y faisait mon truc
c'était que j'y pense et jusqu'à ce que
ça me fasse plus rien puisse-t-elle même
principe mettant un masseur m'asseoir à
côté pense mon amour y ait ou non cet
emprunt au sébasto habitants ont frère
avait pas son petit guèye a fait une
crise d'épilepsie
pina l'avez lu qu il fallait qu à le
filmer par la crise a créé un fossé
l'immeuble jusqu'à temps que ça se passe
plus rien comme ceux ci ça sort pas
aussi allez pouvoir réagir ça ait choqué
mais c'est la même chose que les deux
c'est un deuil ça ça fait tellement mal
puis ceux qui a qui veulent pas y penser
c'est la quiétude mais de plus en plus
mais quand ils pensent sur pense je
pense à mon deuil a été vraiment
difficile quand ma grand mère est morte
puis je leur voyage est en train de
mourir tout le temps puis je la voyais
tellement toute entrée mourir que
maintenant je suis fait comme ok c'est
ce que maintenant je pense même plus à
des souvenirs de quand j'étais enfant
qui savait bien qui était heureux ces
accès c'est juste c'est penser penser
penser jusqu'à temps qu'ils or il faut
se confronter à ses idées qui sont
plates le petit attaquant injustement
ultra pas que leurs grands parents morts
parce qu'ils vieillissent pileux ça ne
peut pas accepter que ses tarifs dans
visser c'est dur et il profite des
moments que l'opt d'avoir bloqué pour
laurie pansu plus quand ça arrive bel
été détruits d'été mais c'est sûr qu'on
était des fois moi j'ai tendance à être
trop négatif à laisser les gens je me
fais tout en et scénarios le métier
c'est des scénarios trousses constipé
dans des abîmes déjà
si tu penses quand ça va arriver mais
moi je suis prêt à tout et c'est
exactement ce que je fais je me coupe
les cheveux bang première harley
terrible qui désirent une évasion nous
sommes bien qu est ce que tu veux mais
pour pas qu'ils me pong comme étant le
premier 24 heures les premiers 24 heures
ce qui va arriver c'est qu'ils vont
appeler chez nous peut-être police
obilalé le gouvernement appelle ça y'est
évasion et me dit ah non j'ai pas une
troupe a fait était parfait
aïe aïe jean amazon des femmes attendant
ses amis au chai à banache cette
influence a ensuite donné des affaires
c'est le studio le contraindre à faire
le tour des stocks
ah oui c'est pas vous qui avait fait
assez confortable c'est du vent le nom
s'est clos des sablons et claudel
d'éclopés de claude mainon mais c'est
parce qu'on va avoir une à d'avec point
compagnie de marc les deux rives c'est
que tu appelles cgi page chaude 1 2
on a tout fait c'était pas moi je savais
comment me préparer ce qui compte c'est
ce qui marche et ça fait genre deux
hommes sont perdus en forêt puis ont
déjà commencé à bollaert gourdon à corps
plein régime plein mais boivent leur
pièce par ça fait plaisir sans perdre
mais je parie qu'ils en savent rien
apporté par apple mais peut-être genre
de poisson un téléphone lundi comme la
larme qu'il y avait eu pour hi hi hi hi
sony non thiaw laye ont dit il ya une
bombe atomique avait explosé
oui bon c'est vrai mais des gens qui ont
barricadé petite défaite leur apporte
oui
c'est alors savoir une fausse alerte oui
life au salaire fossekall c'est aux gens
c'est des trucs dont la partie mais les
mets ont dû rembourser les gens j'espère
bref moi ça arrivait le gouvernement
j'espère qu'il me qui misaient inquiet
pour mes cheveux mais dès qu'ils
appelleraient je me couvre les cheveux
ensuite de tueur je mords à
saint-hyacinthe chez mes parents projet
loup c'est la ville la plus éculée mais
par angèle et mais je découpe coco râpée
sièges mais jean moulin jeu le plus
petit mais mais mais c'est le sport et
le tube au courage de poser
je ne sais pas quelle quelle arme que je
prendrais je pense que je prends si j'ai
vraiment un côté beaucoup d'émissions de
pièces sûrement votre fusil mais
résistent assez non plus faciliter les
jeux vingtaine braindead non c'est quoi
ta chance et quand 200 ans 200 armes de
temps de s'asseoir ensemble c'est quand
même ce métier par les gemmois jeté un
peu exagéré mais saab
j'en aurai un insuffisant c'est pour me
déplacer
ouais parce que une auto falloir que tu
larmes tu remets du gaz et dans mon
année un cheval ça va être servi en plus
d'amis parce que tu manques tout le
monde un moyen autour de toi ça peut
aller quand même vite un cheval puis les
a mis dans ma tête
ils vont pas aller vite annoncer ce
petit peu les faux chèques ton catane
oms et c'est exactement mais je pense
que honnêtement ça arrivait je pense que
je mourrais après de ce qu'on
recherchait la première depuis la
préparation la cdcg peu de talent ne va
pas parler le pee wee écoute plus est
ils sont un peu pour l'heure six mois
pour les fans blague mais quand tu es
bon plat
le flèche maltais sur le cheval ailé
cheval vapeur jetons plein mais j'avais
pensé à cheval une moto ou un 6 mai
maths ou encore l'aide peut pas défendre
cette mince me dont tu cas par cas même
si tu as une voiture à combustible pour
aller la station service qui va sûrement
avoir un code qui va de moins en moins
avant décembre h et pour les autos
électriques c'est trop long à charger
ouais et vous il nous reste onze femmes
mais quoi c'était quand tu étais quand
non mais n'importe quoi n'importe quoi à
promettre comme tu arrêtes pour qui
manger tout cru
non mais ils n'arrêtent pas longtemps
mais c'est que les chevaux sont nerveux
t puis jamais fait de cheval
j'en ai déjà fait de l'équitation
il faudrait qu'un d'équitation new skies
maux de tête et j'ai noté t il
l année passée l'excitation les autres
d'être allé m'entraîner
non mais moi j'ai fait j'ai fait
beaucoup d'excitation qu'on sait pas où
j'en ai fait beaucoup et puis j'aimais
vraiment ses appuis à mon avis depuis
pas que j'allais vraiment vraiment envie
de me dire quelque chose peut être mon
frère
une moto j'ai pas convaincante sur ses
appuis georges s'est fait du scooter en
thaïlande mais se méfie 3 x 3 ça va te
dis c'est plus dangereux mais j'aime
tellement cela en parler des charges par
le tout en utilisant aussi un tireur fou
qui arrive à radio canal je pense que ça
c'est plus probable c'est plus près
c'est plus possible sur qui déshabille
les amis c'est probable mais c'est plus
les abus c'est probable a regardé
plusieurs fois la vidéo teaser qui prend
de la drogue crocodile vie web qui
mangent à face de l'autre ouais c'est
pas mal et c'est un vidéo sur ses skis
le plus proche dans un mobile mais j'ai
écouté par une fois non mais il ya une
sorte de drogue qu'ils genre je pense en
californie puis ils deviennent tellement
montgueux lequel il y avait 1 go qui
était-il trop top qui mangeait la phase
de notre gueule mais su filmer au nom
mais jamal avoir écouté c'est maintenant
au centre hospitalier elle est arrivée
plus genre ils sont maîtres serris
gollop y avait comme une force
surhumaine comme il mangeait des combats
le plus proche en indiquant trouvaille
effectuée
c'est probable si le corps humain si
l'être humain peut il ya deux fils qui
peut se toucher pour faire ce ça se
pourrait que ça suffit les quand on
croise logeant la cafuc avec cette
drogue ça sera là et foyer tout le monde
plutôt bon de faire des amis moi j'ai
pas que ça arrive en même temps
d'écouter neuf ans que j'aimerais qu'ils
avaient eu vent
si ça règlerait la surpopulation
rapidement ça va pas ça veut pas que les
gens les plus gentils qui vont assez
sage et c'est que les gens plus fort
telle est la travailleuse sociale qui a
aidé tout le monde m'a vite mais moi qui
ai le temps pendant des journées
entières de penser à comment j'aime
faire bouffer par les mbi j'ai plus
préparés ouais c'est ça que tu es tout
seul rapidscan des cancers idée
cp pas gilles parent écoutez films des
émissions de samedi est prévue ce week
end est atteint ouais enfin c'est
vraiment intéressant parce que en même
temps qu est une émission de m6 émission
sur la sociologie mais l'entente tuc et
ils sont beaucoup trop ongles ouais
ouais ouais ils sont trop équipe et
pourrait pour les situations mais ça
c'est six états unis aussi nom n'a pas
autant d'hommes
tant mieux mais en même temps pic des
outils communs avec le canadien et on
gère les armes à feu mais ça peut nous
mettre dans mardi à dénoncer les abus et
moi je vais surtout tandis faudrait que
shirt avec 1,2 dollar mais juste pour
être comme c'est que j'avais plus ces
informations le vite avoir trois ou
quatre minutes avant vous l'a dit le
général au général veut pas être envoyée
c'est peut-être ça la prochaine à fond
sa hot 100 avec une personne mais dont
le monde qui cherche des partenaires
pour leur statut le tu cherche un
partenaire au placé en larmes et juste
pour être sûr que si la shit frappe le
fun soit au courant un rapidement des
bras ministre puis justin et répond pas
mais j en valais nous lisent aussi comme
des automassages simba pressaient très
bon beau et en paix sa mangue ainsi vu
en vrai c'est plus mignon bien vu bien
vu il ya vu mais mes premiers pas
s'imagine tout les sites que kate
apprend le jour où ça devient premier
ministre at il ajouté si à notre temps
rempli d'affaires de ces crimes
je ne sais pas si ça existe pour ma
chérie bas aux états unis je le crois
plus à ses côtés des états unis sur fond
des crimes et à des crimes de guerre qui
sont cachés de tête
longtemps choqué kg nazis à des pôles à
machin les américains cage des nazis
ok j'ai pas d'arguments pour défendre
city merci j'ai pensé que ça soit l'être
les petites routes ni encore pensent que
les états unis cachent des six états
unis cache du navigateur
[Rires]
moi je crois qu'il ya des affaires comme
ça que le projet aux états unis qu'il
est président après le président elian
on le sait depuis 1955
mais pas des affaires genre surnaturel
mais très juste
justement des crimes de guerre disait ce
qui est des erreurs qui en fait que
jenson caché le peu que je suis sam à
ben laden ce n'est pas lui qui joue
vraiment des dossiers en dessous du
tapis douay du ca serait genres et les
bonnes carnaval est un costume celui ci
se pose est la même personne de madame
carnaval vous être la même personne qui
le fait depuis le début et non disposé
ces générations je n'attendais pas grand
fils le nom mais comme le père noël même
tout le temps non c'est juste parce que
le bonhomme carnaval cd rom à ce que tu
parles mais non c'est là bas on sait que
ça me fait encore plus peur oui par la
bonne car jamais personne tout le temps
mais n'ont fait boire carnaval le
carnaval c'est comme s'il sortait il est
pas à place laurier même temps que
garder le cap town mais non oui non
wen en a plusieurs qui mettait tu
connais plus clairement passé jean
québec 1
je suis dans les commentaires laissés
nus savoir s'il ya plusieurs bonhomme
carnaval parce que moi honnêtement je
pense pas que plus qu'un mot longue
caravane simultanément à des endroits ça
sonne comme un gros terrien total à la
grosseur tout à ça mais bon j'espère que
je me fais qu'aller pour de rien en fait
l'aspartame intéressant pour toi parce
que c'est mon terrain d'un groupe
étranger raison hakim accusé montre
houle maison qu'est ce qui est plus
chaud autres indices en paix une patate
chaude
c'est un vieux débat qu'ils ont une
patate chaude quotidien patate chaude au
serment jeudi à berlin que c'est shawn
pas la chose plus on était autour du feu
qui s qui plus tôt ou tard il y avait
des gros t'aider à la brasil en boule de
la braise orange le flux rss évolution
n'est pas obligée de passer à travers
l'histoire au complet tout pour dire que
milieu du débat où est ce que je
tenterai me battre pas tant de choses
tel choc un tison le je me rends compte
que j'ai clairement pas raison sauf que
là à ce moment le jeune hamza la merde
quand j'avais tort fait que j'ai juste
continué à quai c'est sûr que c'est
difficile habiter avec toi en trop mais
là je suis meilleur que j'étais
n'entrait pas dans la même forêt chauffé
par une patate chaude qu'un tison
définitivement définitive définitivement
fait que se situe à celle factory temps
même quand on prête à tchô doit être
brûlée la bouche crottes d'azun dans une
halle à bright encore la sensation bout
des doigts oui j'ai tout c'est juste à
ce stade trop 4 1 chez la cabane à sucre
pas de dernier d'or puis mama sarah a
joué dans la braise métier comme c'était
comme juste testé comme un peu blanchi
en dessus à la brèche chaude chaude
qui a dit que c'est du sable
j'ai mis mes deux maintenant bien précis
pendant trois mois la des bandages même
si c'est comme monter des achats se fait
que j aucune conscience du danger
jamais non jamais jamais jamais dit je
veux fois c'est important de le faire
parce que justement si je me dis à qui
il faut que je montre que je suis
capable de refaire faut que je me montre
que je préfère puis à des fois que j'ai
été agent remettons en thaïlande tout
seul puis je me promenais impie sait
jamais je n'avais pas hip hop j'avais
pris par paris comme acquis
ça montre que je capable mais si elle
est quelqu'un qui m'aurait parlé là
pourquoi deux salles besoin de montrer
qu'on est capable de faire mais c'est à
moi même le sait montrer moi même qui
est capable je me sentais qu'on veuille
ou non il faut qu'elle fasse mes
attentes je peux faire exprès je parlais
dans les palais place est plus chaude
déjà allé dans les places comme qui font
pas trop parler des séries comme en
corée du sud
un papa israël popper
mais israël en même temps que j'ai pris
dans le quartier shy'm et soeurs en
palestine mais 6h avec mes amis juifs
ok t'as pas de conscience mettons des
dangers réels mais c'est un trait de tdh
c'est un peut avoir le goût du danger
mais des mouches c'est un peu comme toi
je partage ses coups dj mois ces
jugements rend pas compte
c'est comme si c'était un autre mais ce
que j'ai lu c'est comme si c'était un
stimuli quitter comme ailleurs pour un
tdah à déplacer mais tombera qu'à
acheter car j'étais petit j'aimais pas
raflé qui moi je pense que maintenant je
vais quand même j'ai perdu toutes mes
dents cinq ans mais je m'étais lancé
dans notre en plein mes parents langage
ouais j'ai perdu un groupe de langue ça
leur poussée
pour causer des dégâts dans les balkans
même si les abeilles à beaucoup de monde
qui m'ont inscrite et immobilières sur
internet parce que dans mes vidéos vu
que c'est pas de bonne qualité des fois
sa cravate est le même je dis dis moi
rosalie et dessus des petits gâteaux on
a des fois au québec
c'est sous ce nom mais chez moi c'est ça
mais ça me sidère que la langue repousse
mais je sais pas ça repousse pas en quoi
c'est pourtant ici ça paraît pas les
énormes avant ok c'est ça ça pour
pousser c'est juste que tu le trimestre
chutant possible mais c'est mes deux
doigts mon post impose au fond parce que
c'est trop petit c'est soit à langast
mesurait 6 pouces qu'en cas sortait au
bain alors poussé
ouais exactement cinquante tout et
d'adultes n'ont pas encore de titre avec
toi tout perdu c'est dingue ce c'était
la radio
en fait il y en inquiéter comme je sais
chambranlante pas qu'ils m'ont mis des
broches que s'ils étaient toutes
détruites ils m'ont mis des bourses
d'avoir la gueule un ipad sauvetat chez
mon oncle au cul ouais si j'avais
regardé les olympiques massal comme
capable à lui tout seul ça s'est passé
la même année de fac à garder les gens
pensaient que mes parents me battais
j'avais les mains c'est quand gomis
avant la crème glacée j'aime les dm je
mettais des c'est vraiment dégueulasse
mais télé que mcafee les deux cycles moi
j'en mettais dans mes culottes georges
ordonné aux gens que j'aime et en
garderie pendant 1 journée qu'ont des
services ou des affaires comme ces gens
j'étais dealer jeudi leur garde et qu'il
est fort peut-être continuer ses très
grandes ah non non non c'est tendance à
pousser des cubes de sucre véhicules
dans mes culottes et dans mes souliers
parce que j'avais des siècles des
zappeurs me détruit des tombes des
services aux gens gardent
donne moi ta place à tafer ou donne moi
un peu plus est à collation et c'est on
va jouer par l'anti de la récré on va
jouer au bébé puis c'est moi qui ferment
mais s'ajuste j'agisse beaucoup trop
intelligent pour mon nom je pensais
faire presser ça je s'arrêter à ça il
fallait chargé sais pas si vous faites
cela comme vous voulez mais moi mon rêve
ce serait de revenir aux primaires mais
avec la personnalité que j'ai maintenant
envie de montrer à quel point c'est trop
et déjà je pense à ça des fois je
repense à des événements qui sont
produits quand j'étais au primaire au
secondaire je m'y tiendrai ça être moi
puis le garage etc au mas-d'azil de 27
ans puis le que mon enfant soit vraiment
des filles à mon secondaire il m'avait
dit tu savais comme une vieille grand
mère parce que je m'habiller comme
hipster may 12 ans j'écoutais des films
d'auteur à 13 ans je me trouve trop être
tu m'avais dit erding romain j'aimerais
tellement serré agir maintenant
mais le seul instant mais j'étais trop
l'usure j'avais dit pourquoi
le havre est plus important que avec
maintenant je vais 10e j'avais tout le
monde fait comme en non dit est loser
métissé qui voudraient quand j'ai
repensé à ces deux états cohabitant
aujourd'hui piguet comme ça qu'on a tous
très mal j'en serais fou de sujet
j'avais quand même temps personne dans
le nombril en fait elle n'est pas perçue
d'année
j'en ai la pierre mais jamais dans le
nom brille jamais un oui parce que
j'avais peur de tomber enceinte que ça
déchire
il disait ça m'épate doit pas faire de
personnes tombent en baisse par rapport
aux tendances un pic ça déchire ci tombe
enceinte
et puis moi toutes les filles qui a les
personnes tchèque en 11 ans west backing
band 14 soit seule elle est calme car
j'étais j'avais 14 ans je détestais les
autres filles qui étaient comme qui
prenait trop de temps pour la leur et
tout ce qu'elle est maintenant rentré je
m'en fous rires je connais monte fsu
unsa grand-bassam j'aime plus que moi ou
essayé au métier à 14 ans j'aurais
tellement jugent ils
mais du fait que tu vu ta première
graine à 13 à 14 ans n'avait pas aux
tombées enceintes non non je n'avais pas
de temps de tomber enceinte qui m'attend
cave n3 injustement 5e 10 à déchets mon
penser qu'elle peut pas de tendances
majeures un piercing téton mais quand on
y est 14h50 ouais ouais fallait comme
stan jamais grands pas ok ça mal famés
mettant la gaieté enfants oui j'ai mon
show enfin voie qui passe un peu partout
au québec
est ce que vous voulez venir le voir je
fais à victoriaville la main sont pas
plus loin du tout éventuel et je fais ma
première des montréalais les 12 et 13
novembre
où est la place des arts cool ouais il
faut que je pense beaucoup de bien
cool et on a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
laissé comme mes cinq sens beaucoup de
ces gens mais c'est un exemple parfait
c'est vraiment mais j'en ai plein mais
pas mais vous pourriez pays bas
l'espagne à passer quoi le si vous avez
encore points comme cool pas fait on va
aller voir ce
allez merci beaucoup à la ferme et douce
oui j'aimerais me décrire cet accord
bouzid et bobo pas ce que je fais de
kraft mais des jeunes et moins jeunes
j'ai fait jésus où ils purent y est mais
c'est pas ça drôle
[Musique]